s'agissant des annulations de crédits
elles sont techniquement égal aux
ouvertures vous indiquez monsieur lis
que ces annulations pop own large part
sur des crédits reportés certes mais je
vais peut-être dirait présenter les
choses d'une autre manière puisque vous
reporter j'ai bien écouté ce que vous
avez dit des crédits non consommés
uniquement pour pouvoir les annuler
ce qui interroge et à la date d'ailleurs
où nous avait transmis le projet de
décret vendredi dernier les crédits
disponibles sur la mission par exemple
plan d'urgence était de 155 millions
d'euros seulement alors que le décret en
alu les 3 milliards 5
soit 20 fois plus mais depuis samedi 11
arrêté de report sont parus au journal
officiel
ainsi ce matin même vous avez reporté
plus de 5 milliards d'euros non post
mais en 2021 sur les programmes du plan
d'urgence vers les mêmes programmes en
2022 mais aussi par rapport croisés d'un
milliard d'euros vers le programme 367
qui financent pourtant les prises de
participations financières
sens et vous en conviendrez lien direct
avec la crise sanitaire vous avez donc
utiliser la réserve de but et
budgétisation vous aviez constitué fin
2021 en refusant d'annuler des crédits
non consommés
le décret d'avancé pour être gagé
puisque la limite du 31 mars dès demain
est respectée certes le décret davance
stricto sensu n'accroît pas le déficit
budgétaire mais c'est bien le cas en
revanche des reports qu'il implique les
autres annulations de crédits porte sur
la quasi totalité des missions des
ministères vous l'avez évoqué sauf la
mission aide publique au développement
pourquoi avoir choisi par exemple de
préserver les crédits cette mission est
en soi même peut que s'en réjouir alors
que ceux de la mission défense par
exemple sont les plus concernés par les
annulations valeur absolue en dépit du
caractère essentiel que représente non
seulement le maintien mais le
développement des moyens de la défense
nationale j'ai bien lu pour citer vous
propose sur les eaux sociaux qu'il
s'agit deux mouvements de crédit
temporaire qu'ils seront rétablis en
plfr
j'ai entendu les mots
que vous avez utilisé légèrement
différent dans votre exposé parce que le
ministre des comptes publics sinon est
ce qu'il nous confirme que le décret
d'avancé finalement ne respectent pas
les règles de la lolf à laquelle
pourtant je vous sais pas retirement
attaché ou alors uniquement de manière
formelle et puis finalement il appose en
rites et des ouvertures nettes de crédit
en outre comment pouvez vous annoncer
d'ores et déjà le contenu d'un projet de
loi qui ne relèvera pas de votre
gouvernement
mais de celui qui résultera du ou des
choix faits par les électeurs dans les
prochaines semaines tout ça pour dire
que de toute façon nous aurons un
nouveau gouvernement à moins toutefois
que vous ne prévoyez de présenter et
dans ce cas là il faut nous le dire
maintenant apple fr avant les élections
législatives
au total ce décret davance répond c'est
une évidence et une nécessité mais il
continue de poser un certain nombre de
questions et j'aurai l'occasion demain
matin de présenter devant notre
commission une analyse plus approfondie
encore de ce que des conclusions que ne
que j'en tire pour cette commission
[Musique]